I want to start by asking you about
Cliff Curtis and what it was like
working with him as a scene partner
because I feel like we need more of him
in this industry he is crushing it but
the more we talk about him the better
Cliff is just wonderful I mean he I
think he and I both wanted to play these
parts because of these characters
commitments to family he's very much a
family man
um and that sense of community and his
Maori Heritage was something that he
really I felt
um both consciously and subconsciously
was able to bring into this role
tonawari is such a powerful figure and I
feel that Cliff brings that as an actor
um and he's very warm and very inclusive
and kind and yeah we just really work
together and and and had a great time it
was a fantastic experience it's not
surprised me to hear that I don't know
how much backstory work you two did but
I was wondering if you ever figured out
any experiences they might have had in
terms of why ronal is a little more
hesitant than he is to welcome Jake
Natori and their family into the clan we
I think what I felt was very important
to come convey is the sense that Renault
is absolutely The Matriarch she is the
leader of her clan and I think she will
stop at nothing to protect that and to
protect what they have created they
really care for and look after not just
their family but that entire Village
that entire Community the mecca Ina clan
um and so the idea that anything from
the outside could pose any sort of
threat is something that I think as a
mother she just instinctively feels and
feels very wary of
um she loves her little tribe she loves
her family she wants them to have their
freedom and not be in any way I suppose
restricted or um
yeah possibly kind of threatened
so yeah it was it was important to me to
really play that side of her you feel it
very much so I did want to ask about the
the underwater performance capture of it
all and I was curious is there anything
about acting for the camera in that kind
of environment that you've found I don't
know highlighting something else in your
craft that you're now able to take into
your live action work or is it
completely separate
um it's such a totally different
experience and in many ways motion
capture is almost a it's almost the most
pure form of acting and people wouldn't
really think that because
you know you don't see us as real people
you see the Blue version of us as actors
but in order to capture that you know
you have cameras watching you from every
angle you also have a helmet
and a helmet cam that is capturing every
single muscle and movement in your face
so you can't hide even your eyeballs the
movement of your eyeballs is captured
and so in terms of performance you
really have to deliver because you want
that camera to see every single thing
that you're doing because you want as
much of your facial muscles to be
repeated in your Nazi version of
yourself so it's a quite an intense
demanding experience but I absolutely
loved it oh and with a silly one because
I've heard a little bit about a swear
jar were you someone who added to the
swear jar often and if so what is the
word that got you in the most trouble
well it's a word that begins with f
um and yes I was the one who got in the
most trouble Trinity would be regularly
Kate
that's five dollars yeah yeah I got in a
lot of trouble most days
um and was very out of pocket because of
the swear jar okay fair enough fair
enough I hear hear they did some good
things with uh the money so it was well
worth every f word you gave them there
you go perfect